[Music]
archaeologists sure lead exciting lives
you might think that they spend their
days examining old trinkets and writing
dry papers on their findings but that's
really not the case at all instead their
voyage into exotic islands traipsing
through beautiful environments
plundering ancient tombs and fighting
scores of maniacal men at least that's
how Laura props working hours play out
Tomb Raider may have a silly story but
it's so much fun to investigate the
mysterious ruins and kill the many bad
guys they're going to be to absorb decay
still you do have to sit through
cutscenes to bring to life just how poor
the plot is there's a control freak at a
mysterious island - well is after more
control so he's busy replicating ancient
rituals in order to realize his godlike
potential
he's a predictable megalomaniac and the
supporting characters don't light any
fires either
however Laura herself is quite
interesting for voyage from determined
scientist to defeated survivor is
relatable and Ashley becomes stronger
with each new success you grow along
with her her loyalty to her friends is
unwavering as is her commitment to kill
anyone who poses a threat yeah it's a
little unbelievable how quickly she
becomes accustomed to the killing
lifestyle but even though her
development feels a bit rushed she still
feels somewhat real
the fast-moving plot is mitigated by the
slow pacing of your progress Tomb Raider
plops you in huge environments let you
explore at your leisure they're ancient
doodads hidden all over the place and
climbing up walls and walking across
narrow pathways gives you a chance to
relax and admire the many gorgeous
sights
they're also tombs to explore obviously
this is where you have to test Laura's
puzzle-solving abilities you have to
figure out how to reach seemingly
unreachable places and these brief
forays do a great job of giving you
interesting non violent side activities
of course there's still plenty of
fighting Laura moves with speed in the
throws of warfare and movement is
imperative because she can die with only
a few shots blinking behind cover and
then sprinting the higher ground is so
freeing that you find yourself
constantly on the run though you can
hunker down if you prefer just watch out
for fire bombs each fight only lasts a
few minutes so combat never overstays
its welcome and there are lots of
different scenarios to keep you on your
toes
Laura sports the expected assortment of
guns pistols shotguns assault rifles you
know the drill and though firing these
feels perfectly fine the real joy comes
from her bow and arrow
I loved sneaking up on an unsuspecting
fool and then popping him in the head
and then turning my sights on his buddy
before he could sound the alarm and if
your aim is cruel
you can hit them in the knee and then
finish them off with a melee shot yeah
it's dangerous to stay in the open but
it's also so satisfying that it's worth
the risk
but solo adventure stretches on for
dozens of hours if you're striving to
map every collectable which is how I
played and just about every minute is
riveting Laura slowly finds new tools so
you can tear down structures with a rope
bow or blast down doors with a shotgun
this gives you access to more parts the
environments and revisiting past
locations with new powers lets you see
even more of the expansive wall
[Music]
so all the single-player stuff is good
fun but the multiplayer well not quite
don't get me wrong the sharp controls
are just as responsive and there's
undeniable pleasure and hitting someone
in the jaw with an arrow but everything
feels so predictable we've seen
third-person shooters play out like this
before and the lack of surprise leaves
monotony but thankfully multiplayer is
an optional part of an otherwise great
game the definitive edition sports
better textures lighting and other
technical feats from its Xbox 360 and
PlayStation 3 counterparts but that's
besides the point
it's how the cutting-edge tech
complements that fantastic art design
that makes this game look so appealing
and the action is just as enthralling
Tomb Raider is a great reinvention of
this enduring franchise that makes the
eager to see where lore goes in the
future
[Music]
you
[Music]